(pleasant music)
- Okay, so you've met
Sophia. You've met Michelle.
- Hi.
- [Kelly] Bringing people together.
- I am.
- [Kelly] Even the ones alive.
(people laughing)
So, you've read thousands
of people over the years.
- Yes.
- Have you ever had one
that's just freaked you out?
- Not from people who have crossed over,
but from the living people
that I've actually read from.
- That actually tracks.
- Yeah, so, way back in the day,
I used to go to people's homes
and I would do like a house party.
So, it was kinda like,
take out the Tupperware,
bring in the psychic kind of vibe.
Yeah. So, I would be the person
they would shove in a
basement somewhere and then,
you know people would have
coffee and cake and...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I would read them.
So, I had one night where I was completed.
I thought I was done.
And a woman said to me,
"No, you can't leave yet."
And I said, "Why can't I leave?"
And she goes, "We have a
very special guest coming."
And I'm like,
"I don't think I really
have another reading in me."
And she said, "Oh no, no-
you have to have another reading in you."
And as she's saying that to me,
and she was very nervous,
like four SUVs pulled up.
And I'm like,
- What?
- Yeah, and I'm waiting for like,
somebody like, famous to get out?
And there was nobody that I recognized
that was famous that got out.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But somebody that they
knew, who was famous
and whatever circles they traveled
got out with a lot of bodyguards.
- Oh.
- And that individual was
escorted down to the basement.
I did a reading for said individual,
with six bodyguards in the room.
- Like somebody in the mafia or something?
Like, what were we talking about?
(group chattering)
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I mean, how do you read that situation?
I would only give positive news.
- I will tell you that, you would laugh
but for people who know me know
that my daughter calls me the
Gordon Ramsey of psychics.
So, like about 15 minutes into the reading
when he wasn't validating anything
I was like, "Dude. Like
you either have this
or you don't have this."
- Yeah.
- And then all he said to me was,
"So, the woman upstairs
has your information
and if ever I need to call upon you,
you will make yourself available."
- You will make yourself- oh.
- [John] That's what I was told.
Yeah. And I changed my
phone number after that.
(people laughing)
- Was this like a sheikh or something?
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Or along the lines of what Kelly-
- You will make yourself available.
It sounded like the mafia.
- Yeah. It was not a
comfortable experience.
- [Michelle] That's gangster man.
(group chattering)
Oh, literally.
(Michelle laughs)
- Literally.
So, wait, how does your
family react to your ability?
Do they just go, "Don't read
me, don't read anything."
- I don't like to read
my family. I don't like-
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah?
- Yeah. I don't wanna
read people that I know
because then I know stuff about them that,
maybe I don't want to know.
- Sometimes I have to see stuff
that I don't want to know.
- Yeah, I'm that person too.
I don't need to know everything.
I'm not that, I'm not curious like that.
- So, I've been doing
this for four decades.
So, over the years you kind of learn like,
yeah, I don't wanna do that anymore.
- You turn it on and off?
- You have to be able
to turn it on and off,
because if not, then you're walking around
energetically receptive
to other people's energies
and you don't want to take
on other people's stuff.
- Do y'all have anything
that you wanna ask him?
I don't know.
- Ooh...
- Uh...
(group laughs)
- In front of all these wonderful people?
- She said, "Uh..."
- How did you get into it?
- So, I... that's a good question.
- [Kelly] It is a good question.
- I actually went to debunk a psychic
that was doing readings
at my grandmother's house.
- Oh wow.
- I wanted to prove to my
family that it wasn't real
and that she wouldn't
be able to read for me.
So, my mom said, I was 15,
my mom said I was allowed to go as long
as I treated the woman with respect.
I was all, "I'll treat her with respect,
but I ain't helping her."
And I was blown away. She changed my life.
- Wow.
- She literally, she told
me I had this ability.
The reason why she was there
that day was put me on my path.
And I, I thought she was kind of crazy.
But it was a... I didn't
love it, to be honest.
I know it sounds crazy,
but I always tell people
if you're not ready for a
real reading, do not go.
Because I was not ready
for a real experience
and I felt violated.
So, my development came
as a result of wanting
to make sure nobody else could
ever do that to me again.
- It must be really hard too,
living in a scientific world, you know?
- Yeah.
- I mean we've fought so hard,
I think especially in America,
to separate church from state
and to have the liberty of
being able to prove things,
true or false.
And the proof in the
pudding is kind of like...
- [John] And that's, that's why-
- This generation, you know.
- For me I was very, I was very blessed.
I had the opportunity to go
to the University of Arizona
and be studied with Dr. Gary Schwartz,
and he wrote a book called
The Afterlife Experiments.
And myself and another,
a number of mediums
have gone out there three or four times.
And in science, you have to replicate
and extend data, right?
To show the validity, to rule out
that you're reading body
language and facial cues.
And we did all of that.
But, I adopted that in my practice
because I want people to recognize
that it's important in
our society right now
to be a critical thinker.
And just because somebody
says to think this way
or feel this way, or believe this way,
whether it be pastor,
teacher or politician,
always makes sure you're questioning
and thinking about the validity
of what they're saying.
And more importantly,
where is their intention coming from?
- Yeah. What's the motivation?
- Yeah, are they trying to empower you
or are they trying to control you?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Wow. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(people clapping)
I think that's actually pretty cool
because you actually love
that people question you.
- [John] ] I do.
- Yeah. I love that.
- [John] I like validation.
So, like sometimes,
somebody will come to me
because they desperately
want to hear from one person.
And I wind up connecting with four others,
and sometimes I have to
connect with four others
before I can get to the one person
that they want to hear from.
So, I always feel like
I'm your psychic dog.
I'm like, when the dog
does the thing right,
you give him a treat.
And for me, the treat is validation.
- Yeah.
Have you ever picked up
on something that like...
the person didn't want to,
you didn't necessarily ask,
but you felt inclined,
you had to say something?
- Oh, it just happened last week.
I was in Detroit and I
wound up reading for a woman
who was with her mother-in-law,
and their family came
through and announced
that she was pregnant.
And she had this like
moment of being like...
and then she's like,
"She doesn't know yet!
This is my mother-in-law."
And she was like, "Yes, it's true."
So like, moments like that happened.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- Yeah.
- For people who can't see you in person,
you have another way to connect.
That's pretty cool. So, what is it?
- I do, so if folks are interested
in the subject matter, not
only am I going on tour
but I am just launching
an online community.
So, they can go to johnedward.net.
- Okay. So you, when you go on tour
that's a huge room filled with people.
That's not overwhelming, that many people?
- No, the the most
overwhelmed I could ever say
that I was, I did an
arena tour in Australia.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they were like, well you would know.
I, I mean like that-
- [Kelly] No, I mean, I get it.
If I'm just projecting something out,
I'm not necessarily- and I
guess I am receiving too,
like energy from the audience.
But that's, that could be overwhelming.
Like just pending on
what's happening. You know?
- It was when I walked out there
in front of like, you know, 7,000 people.
- I was like, what am I gonna do?
And then I realized it didn't matter
if it was 7,000 or seven,
the people who were
supposed to get the message
were going to get the message
and I was gonna do my job as best I can.
- You had to let go and be your best self.
- And then educate and
empower the other people
that were there to hear.